well hey you guys
here's our movie retrospective so this
is the movie that overwhelmingly won the
poll this is actually the only movie in
the poll that got any votes this is a
good move he's got all the votes this is
a good movie i've never seen it so it
does seem like uh you guys and please
correct me if i'm wrong but you guys do
seem to want us to do like more 60s and
maybe 70s stuff rather than like newer
stuff because i usually try to put like
kind of a classics yeah
well yeah we haven't done that many and
you know remember when we did like a
couple of 50 sci-fi ones and a lot of
people were like oh you should do more
of these and stuff like that and i do
kind of feel like we need to go back and
probably do because a lot of really good
uh horror movies came out in the 1960s
and this is absolutely one of them now i
wanted to see this one i saw this when i
was a kid or maybe like a teenager and i
remember really liking it but i don't
think i'd seen it since then i've never
seen it i've only seen um
excerpts from it it looked interesting
back then now see it was like wow it's
[ __ ]
there's a lot of classic movies out
there that are good that inspired other
movies that came out later this one this
is like
looks like it inspired misery oh big
time yeah um which is that's a good
stephen king book that was made into a
movie
but this movie was it was good man it
was good it kind of reminded me of
crosstalk like psycho and the loved one
you know it had that feel to it
1960s california it's very california to
say the settings and the the culture of
the movie
hollywood you know it's about hollywood
stars
in their old age it's weird man um
good it's way
ahead of his time
uh creepy i liked it yeah it is very
creepy and it um it is almost kind of
like it has a lot of black humor to it
too it's like satirical and a twist and
a twist in the end yeah stuff like that
and the thing about it sometimes i mean
i really love this movie
um but sometimes i kind of feel like
what part of what makes it good is all
of the like background stuff because if
if younger people didn't know betty
davis and joan crawford who are in this
movie
uh very very famously could not stand
one another i mean
and it was like and it wasn't just from
this movie i mean this was a long-term
feud yeah well they had huge egos both
of them
yeah they were good chicks but they were
what you would call back in the day
hollywood broads
you know they were the first of the
strong independent women i guess you
could say they were mean
mean mean and petty and mean [ __ ] yeah
uh but it's like super i'm sure it
wasn't fun like for anybody to have to
deal with but it's super fun to like
read about
i think that they've recently made i
don't think it's on netflix but it's on
some streaming service i think they've
recently made a series called feud which
is about this i think susan sarandon is
in it and i can't remember who else is
in it but they're playing like uh betty
davis and joan crawford i mean like i
said it was so i think it stemmed from
one thing uh both of them said they both
had like were into the same dude and
they each said they stole them from each
other so there was that i think also
joan crawford
didn't like that betty davis got
nominated for like [ __ ] tons more oscars
than her
like because
you know betty davis ended up like with
10 oscar nominations and joan crawford
only got the one oscar for mildred
pierce and uh which was actually a role
that betty davis turned down so it's
almost kind of like oh i got an oscar
but it was for like betty davis's sloppy
seconds type of thing uh and i think
betty davis thought that joan crawford
wasn't really a serious actress like she
wasn't really all that good so she was
always like super [ __ ] jealousy i
mean yeah so the two like these two
[ __ ] were just like at each other's
throats all the time so it was like
genius
genius casting to put them both in this
movie because every all of the animosity
that you see
between them like other students
absolutely real they absolutely could
not stand each other and it really like
it really like makes this worth watching
yeah and they're both they're both
playing to type uh you know i mean
they're they're almost kind of like uh
well i don't want to say they're playing
themselves it's just that
a little bit maybe [ __ ]
betty and her prime man she was cute but
you know
john crawford was cuter and you could
see that well it was a different kind of
beauty she was much more elegant i feel
like joan crawford maybe
i'm just saying it from a man's point of
view you'd rather hit joe crawford and
hit
betty davis although betty was
in a prime for cool but uh nah man joe
was looking
a lot more attractive and [ __ ] betty
do it that's why she [ __ ] hated her
and that's why they cast her in this
movie because that angle is in this
movie about who's prettier
although i think they aged up betty
quite a bit to make her look rougher she
did she she's in this movie
she basically
basically plays a [ __ ] evil crazy
goth check really running around and an
older woman running around and [ __ ]
girl clothes
[ __ ] creepy
real creepy trying to make the sister
was paralyzed trying to make her eat
dead rats and uncooked dead rats and
[ __ ] make her eat her own parakeet
and [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
it's going out there man and this is you
know this is like one of the first
movies where they show a scene where
some woman just literally just kicks
another woman to she just kicks the [ __ ]
out of her bam bam they don't show it
they cleverly edit it so you don't
actually see a foot hitter
but it does kind of it's although she
absolutely did kick her for real did she
kick her for real yeah because like i
said they hated each other yeah so she
was just like
very similar yeah and to get back at her
so you know the scene where uh where
betty davis has to like drag joan
crawford like out of like after out of
the room or whatever yeah so joan
crawford put on like a weight lifter
belt like under her clothes like to make
herself heavier so it would be harder
for says like
like that's what i mean there was like
petty [ __ ] going on like behind the
scenes of this movie but she absolutely
did kick her and i think she actually
did hurt this is almost kind of like the
original this is almost kind of like an
original horror check flick in a way
it's basically most of the main
characters are women uh there's one guy
who's a character in it uh
but you question whether or not he's
straight or not i was i think he was
supposed i think they were supposed to
well i was supposed to think he was gay
that actor victor bono um
he was he was gay in real life yeah okay
um although he didn't he never came out
but everybody kind of knew yes i figured
that's what was going on this was
actually his first major role he kind of
plays a gay con artist
and trying to con this old lady out of
her money
his facial expressions and this are
priceless yeah
[Laughter]
and then um
uh there's uh
another chick that's in the movie i
don't know her real name she plays a
character named elvira yeah she's like
their housekeeper she's like the
housekeeper that comes up once a week
and she's this uh black chick and she
[ __ ]
knows there's some bad [ __ ] going down
yeah she is not between these two
sisters she tries to protect the good
sister uh but ends up [ __ ] paying
with her life and [ __ ] [ __ ] got took
a [ __ ]
hammer to the head i was going don't put
that hammer down don't put that
she put that
yelling at her if she put the hammer
down and [ __ ] turned her back on
[ __ ]
betty davis and she picked up that
hammer [ __ ] bow [ __ ] you know
while she was trying to save the other
one she had her [ __ ] tied up into bed
[ __ ] it's like a ruthless movie for
the 60s you know that's yeah good the
way it's shot it's real spooky they're
in this old
california spanish mansion somewhere out
in hollywood
hills i guess i don't know but it's just
kind of like that damn drug lords
mansion we almost bought
iron spanish spanish-looking wrought
iron and [ __ ] tile you know [ __ ]
decorative tile it's it's a creepy
looking house when you shoot it in black
and white and low light looks like a
haunted mansion
you know looks like a haunted house that
they live in it's a creepy flick
and it's you could see where stephen
king got his ideas for misery
you know yeah i this it's absolutely i
mean it's like undisputable i give the
movie for [ __ ] five out of five man
especially in the context of the time
that it came out it was like so much
better than i remembered like i said i
hadn't seen it since i was a teenager
but i remember really digging it
i say better than psycho
it's it's up there with psycho yeah um
it definitely does and i feel like
people don't talk about it as much as
they talk about psycho i mean this
definitely is influenced by psycho like
to some extent a lot more dialogue than
psycho that's true but the thing about
it was that this was actually based on a
book
that came out in 1960 so it was like the
same year that psycho came out so it's
not like it could have been that because
it was a it's a book adaptation yeah
this movie came out in 1916. it could
have been a movie that
to compete side by side with psycho in
its time
yeah i mean it's definitely like a
psychological horror um and it has
aspects and like i said it has aspects
of like black humor and almost like camp
but i think that that enhances the
horror rather because it's so grotesque
yeah you know what i mean it's funny
because i feel like the contemporary
reviews like when it came out in the 60s
were
very mixed for that reason because they
said you know these two actresses
they're just like playing caricatures of
themselves and i'm like well that's kind
of the point that's why they cast them
and well the thing about it though was
that this actually this movie actually
ended up getting whatever the critics
said this ended up getting nominated for
five oscars and betty davis was
nominated for best actress she didn't
win
but um that was another source of
contention was that betty davis was
nominated for best actress for this but
joan crawford wasn't yeah but i guess
just because betty davis she has more to
do i mean she it's a showier
role she gets to like go bat [ __ ] insane
yeah whereas joan crawford just kind of
had to sit there and suffer yeah she's
basically playing a character who's kind
of like uh shirley temple she's supposed
to be kind of like an evil shirley
temple when she was a little kid
and now she's older and people have
forgotten about her they don't even know
her character she said don't you
recognize me i'm you know i am baby jane
hudson and they're like who's that they
don't even know who that is and they're
just like oh great but she's still
wearing those [ __ ] clothes but she's
got like little curls little curls and
blowing her hair
yeah and she's how old was she in real
life probably 54. 54. she was 54 i
looked it up because we were curious i
was like i know that she caked all the
makeup on herself another story about
this is that she insisted she do her own
makeup because she said if they had like
a makeup artist do the makeup on me then
everybody would like he wouldn't get any
work again because i looked so grotesque
yeah so she would just like kept piling
like caking all this makeup on her and
she looks like she looks like a [ __ ]
hag and uh yeah and she was younger and
joan crawford was 58 in this really yeah
okay [ __ ] joe was looking a lot
better a lot better but like i said you
know yeah and that's kind of why i think
that betty davis probably got an oscar
nom and
joan crawford didn't because
betty davis went for it i mean she
allowed herself to look like that and to
act like that and so she just like went
all in with it i thought i thought joan
crawford was probably in her mid-40s at
the time that's the way she looked and
yeah
she's actually older she's actually
older so [ __ ] that's amazing which is
which is uh synonymous with the movie
because she was supposed to be that much
older right you know what i mean than
that she didn't look anywhere near 58.
no but like i said betty davis like
caked the [ __ ] on so she would look like
as
grotesque as possible
um yeah so so that's kind of the story
it starts out and like i said i've
forgotten that this movie is actually
quite long it's like two hours two hours
and 20 minutes or two hours and 30
minutes something like that um but it
never seemed like that i just really got
into it
um but yeah so it starts out actually in
1917
and at that point
betty davis's character she's a little
girl
and she's this really really famous like
child star like vaudevillian type thing
so it's like her and her dad
and she's so famous that they have like
all these porcelain dolls made of her
and stuff like that and she's like size
dolls yeah it's that's also super creepy
and that'll kind of like factor in later
but she's also
super spoiled she's like a super brat um
because she's famous she's like [ __ ]
this is all my money she's supporting
the family yeah so blanche her sister
who's a little bit older is obviously
like not the favored one and so she's
just like having to sit there and like
watch while her sister gets all the
attention and her and her mom are just
over there looking all dowdy and [ __ ] uh
so yeah so there's that but then you
jump ahead to the 1930s
and it turns out and this actually does
kind of happen with a lot of child stars
and i kind of feel like that that's a
little bit what this movie was like
satirizing
is that in the
1930s um
actually blanche is now the famous one
um you know she's like this big starlet
and everything and betty davis's
character baby james she's a husband
she's a has-been
now
uh you know because she was a child star
and nobody gives a [ __ ] about that
anymore and like i said that was kind of
like before movies really hit she was
more vaudevillian i guess yeah but it's
now like the hollywood that you know
yeah screen hollywood yeah like 30 like
mid-1930s yeah and the culture's
changing and everything girls running
around on their own girls driving all
that kind of stuff so they were driving
cars dating and going to hotels and [ __ ]
yeah but that was a that was a hollywood
thing only
yeah regular people weren't that wild no
people ahead they were ahead of the
curve they were yeah yeah
but so because of that like now that
she's like now that blanche is the
famous one
she's actually doing a thing where
she'll kind of like throw a bone to her
yeah she's she has a contract with her
studio where she's like well if i'm in a
movie you have to find a part for my
sister as well but all the producers
like don't want the sister betty davis
because she's like a shitty actor she's
also a nut and she's a nut and they
don't like dealing with her and she's a
drunk yeah so they're just kind of like
man it's like it sucks that it's like to
get blanche we have to have baby jane in
there as well said she go through a case
of scotch in a month or was it a week i
thought it was a week or maybe a day i
don't know
i mean she drinks all the booze i mean
all i was making a joke like she calls
the liquor store to get liquor delivery
and i was because even back in the back
in the 60s they had like uber eats for
for liquor delivery but she calls up and
they're like calling the liquor store
and i was like yes please send all the
liquor yes all of it like right not be
invited as well cause she's drinking it
every single [ __ ] she's got empty
bottles up in there
she's like going i'm like holy [ __ ] lady
i thought i drank though she can fake
being drunk
maybe she wasn't faking maybe i don't
know she'd be with the dolls crying and
[ __ ] and then trying to sing her old
songs blanche up there listening to that
crazy [ __ ]
about daddy [ __ ] [ __ ] that's just man
it's pretty it's it yeah it is very
creepy yeah but uh so yeah so
but then what happens in the 1930s
is that somebody
uh there's some kind of accident
uh it's actually it's actually portrayed
as like not an accident but the upshot
of it is
that
blanche uh has her spine snapped and is
now like a paraplegic
and um
baby jane gets blamed for like being
drunk behind the wheel and she hit like
the fence in front of their house or
something like that ran off and they
found her in a hotel with some strange
man yeah and then she ran off and they
found her three days later
so they assumed yeah so they assumed
that um that she had been driving and
that she had crippled her sister so over
the past
you know this movie was like like i said
it's like said in real time they
actually use real movies uh of joan
crawford and betty davis like from the
30s like as their movies in the movie
yeah it's all meta yeah it's very
they're watching themselves as kids it's
very meta
with clips of their old movies of their
movies supposedly other movies that were
never made yeah but uh yes but those
were actual movies so from the 1930s
from that year i think a couple of them
from 1933 and one's from 1934. so uh so
now we jump ahead to the contemporary
time of 1962 so ever since the 1930s
these two have been living together sort
of reclusively like they have money um
because of all their you know stuff but
all their movies and everything but
they're kind of like run into financial
trouble so
when we meet them
so she's been blanche has been a
paraplegic like this whole time and
uh baby jane has been taking care of her
and obviously is not super happy about
it
now so there's been like all of this
kind of like simmering resentment in
there but the catalyst is well there's a
couple catalysts
catalyst being
number one being that blanche is kind of
having a little bit of a career
resurgence because a lot of her old
movies are being shown on tv
uh so she's getting all these fan
letters and stuff like that again like
people rediscovering her so there's that
and also they're kind of like running
out of money a little bit and uh blanche
is like we have to sell the house and
she's kind of low-key on the down low
being like well i'm gonna sell the house
and i'm gonna put this [ __ ] in a home
uh cause she's a drunk and she's getting
a little too crazy
so i need to be an assisted living yeah
so because she had started like
trying to keep it secret that she was
gonna sell the house like a month before
so over the past month before the events
of the movie um you kind of like it sort
of exposited that baby jane's like um
behavior has been getting more and more
erratic yeah if you want to see this
movie and you haven't seen it yet now
it'd be probably time to check off for
the show and come back later because
there's probably gonna be a bunch of
spoilers
i mean this movie is like really really
old it's old but most people probably
haven't seen it i mean i kind of yeah
that's true i kind of feel like this is
one of those ones that
you feel like you should see yeah it's
like oh yeah i need to get around to
that because it's like you know a lot of
people kind of talk about it like if
you've never seen psycho you got to see
psycho yeah yeah and i kind of feel like
you should probably see this one too i
mean it's probably not as i mean psycho
is like iconic but this is also iconic
in its own right if you've never seen
them you got to see them we need to we
need to do a show on that that's the
ultimate 1950s [ __ ] monster movie
atomic [ __ ] monster movie yeah it was
the aliens of today of that day yeah
like i said we probably should do like
more 50s and 60s type stuff because i
feel like we've neglected that a little
bit
but and we've you know we've only done
like a few from the 30s and 70s my dad
saw them when it came out in the theater
when he was a kid he said it scared the
[ __ ] out of him because it looked real
about giant ants
yeah yeah giant ants attack in los
angeles yeah but it was like it wasn't
like one of the like cheap knockouts no
like big bug movies it was actually like
the best yeah they built [ __ ] the
giant real giant ants and [ __ ] army
dudes working out there fighting them
and shooting them up [ __ ] submachine
guns and it looks like live ammo to me
it looks i don't think any of that was
fake
i mean it probably was back in those
days yeah i think they were just like
hey does nobody be in the line of fire
yeah
they look like bullet impacts going off
into the dirt and into those [ __ ]
and i think those were real army troops
they use real army troops and movies all
the time yeah
it's like recruitment drive type stuff
but yeah so
yeah so basically you're seeing
um baby jane as her insanity is like
getting more and more pronounced uh so
she's starting to like i mean i'm
assuming she was tormenting her sister
before like in more sort of subtle
passive-aggressive kind of ways but now
that
you know her sister is getting like some
accolades again and now that she's
thinking about selling the house and
she's like oh [ __ ] she's gonna put me in
a home
then like it starts ramping up you know
what i mean to a point where i mean it
they imply too that she's been stealing
money
because she is she forges her sisters
like blanche's signature right because
blanche can't leave the house and she'd
been stealing money she was that's why
she was hiding all the bottles i think
yeah so so there's that but like i said
it gets up to a thing where you know
she's getting to a point like she said
she kills her bird and like serves it to
her for food um and then like she does
that and then
so blanche won't eat because she's like
afraid every time she brings her a new
tray with food on it she's afraid to
look under there it's like what the
[ __ ] gonna be under there yeah but i'm
just good sometimes it's good but then
like she'll gaslight her into being like
oh you're so neurotic like it's just
look it's normal it's just like a pork
chop or a rib or whatever the [ __ ] it
was um but then like she does that a
couple times and then she's like ta-da
it's a rat you know what i mean it's
like yeah so it's [ __ ] up yeah that's
how elvira really comes into the store
the first time
when the parakeet comes missing elvira
tells blanche she she did that on
purpose that
that
that you know that bird didn't get away
on accident she's she's evil and [ __ ]
blanche doesn't really want to accept it
but
because elvira's not related to her she
can see exactly what what she is
yeah and i think too i and they don't
really like say this outright but i
think the implication was you have to
think that
because you know you get to a thing it's
like come on blanche like get on the
clue bus or whatever but you have to
think that she's been living with her
sister being taken care of by her sister
for
30 years
and her sister while a drunk and while
resentful of her and [ __ ] and stuff
hasn't really like gone to this extent
to this level so i kind of feel like
she's still at the place where you know
she's really all right she wouldn't
really do any of this i don't think
she's really cognizant of how
her sanity has crumbled and how like the
[ __ ] yeah with with her like getting
back into the spotlight and everything
is
you know is taking a toll on her yeah i
like the elvira character though in this
movie because out of all the other
characters that she was the only heroic
character really yeah
even later on when the boyfriend gets
involved
he's a coward he's a coward he runs the
only one that [ __ ] went in there to
try to save her and [ __ ] [ __ ] risked
her life was [ __ ] yeah
virus and she was just the housekeeper i
mean she was friends with blanche t yeah
she'd been there a long time yeah but
she tried to save her from evil she's
like oh no i'm going right the [ __ ] in
there yeah right she confronted it she
confronted it head-on she just made the
mistake of turning her back on [ __ ]
uh what's her name not blanche uh uh jay
jane and jane [ __ ] hit her with the
hammer yeah yeah but that that was a
great scene
it was and well because i kind of feel
like elvira even though she was a lot
more uh you know up on like how crazy
jane had gotten yeah i still don't think
she thought that she would cross the
line and like kill her you know what i
mean because you wouldn't think that i
mean like i said i'm presuming she knew
jane for a long time as well because
like i said she's been working at the
house for a while
so
you know nobody really thinks that it's
going to go to that extent i guess but
the thing about jane like i said she's
kind of losing it so she's been stealing
money the whole time she's been drunk
the whole time but then like she starts
getting crazier and crazier where she
actually thinks because
blanche has had something of a little
bit of a career resurgence she's like oh
well i'm gonna do that too
so she puts an ad in the paper like
looking for somebody who's like plays
piano and like a songwriter and stuff to
help her collaborate and she's going to
go back on the road with her same act
same actor when as when she was a kid
like she's going to have the little
curly hair costumes and everything and
like she has all these costumes made of
like her old dresses and she's going to
go like dance and sing the songs like
and she can't sing anymore either no
well probably all the booze and smoking
another another interesting aspect of
the movie was the neighbors the
neighbors were this is an upper
this is an upper-class neighborhood in i
guess hollywood somewhere
some somewhere outside l.a i guess yeah
um
and uh the neighbors are a mother and a
daughter
they didn't ever show a husband so i
think they were implied that she was a
real successful businesswoman with her
daughter
yeah maybe so they yeah they didn't
really
specify which is kind of interesting
which is kind of unusual for the 60s
but that would have been an unusual
neighborhood and situation for the 1960s
anyway rich single women which with kids
that was that was on yeah although the
daughter was grown she was probably like
in her 20s yeah the daughter was in her
20s and they're interested in the
[ __ ]
old ladies live next door because they
were famous and their movies come on tv
and she wanted to go meet blanche and
jane is being a total [ __ ] you know
about [ __ ] oh no she's not here oh
she's sick she doesn't take visitors all
that kind of stuff
and
the neighbor was
figured something was unusual but she
really couldn't they never really could
put two and two together and blanche was
trying to send secret messages to him
and [ __ ] trying to tell her
like throwing a note out the window and
[ __ ] like that
so there is like a bunch of close calls
but it's an interesting movie because
basically all the main characters are
female which it almost kind of like the
way the thing was all male
it's almost kind of like
a female version of the thing in a
certain way you know what i mean
there's isolation and almost all female
cast
and it's a horror movie kind of did you
notice those parallels
not really but i mean think of it it's
like a
horror chick flick yeah but it's not
but the writing is like is very kind of
like
i don't know
you could also substitute all these
characters for male characters and just
you know what i mean it's just a
realistic story yeah it would work
either way yeah i mean well i don't know
if it would work exactly the same
because i think it's kind of satirizing
a little bit like the way that
particularly female actresses during
this era like once you get into your 40s
or 50s you're like a hag or like a half
man or something like that so i think
they were kind of leaning into that yeah
as well well even the gay character
essentially is a female character in the
in the writing of the movie did you
notice that he's yeah he's kind of he's
just another female character well he's
the thing about victor bono's character
who's like like i said pretty much the
only main male character in this
is that he's the guy that responds to
the ad he can play piano and all this
other kind of [ __ ] but he's like much
younger than her
yeah so he's kind of a big fat guy he
lives with his mom and stuff like that
and he's like looking for work so he
goes there and
he has no idea like because baby jane is
under the impression that everybody
still remembers who she is even though
at this point like in the universe of
the movie this is 1962 she was a child
star back in 1917. it's like most of the
people that would have remembered her
are probably like dead or like old
themselves like young people would not
remember her but she still kind of feels
like that everybody should so this guy i
mean he doesn't really it's really weird
his character because
i think he just wanted money yeah he was
a con man he was just like a con man
like he could he could play piano and
stuff yeah but he was basically just
telling her what she wanted to hear yeah
and it's funny because blanche is not
blanched but jane is so delusional he's
obviously flaming homosexual pretending
to be interested in her
yeah you know
and just telling her what she wants to
do and demanding money quite regularly
yeah and she doesn't see through it
because she's just so so delusional
yeah i think that's why they
made that made sure that that character
was was gay
yeah that to show that she was
delusional yeah that she actually
thought oh she thought that guy was
interested in her was into her yeah and
it's like even if he was straight i mean
how she looked and like how crazy she
was clearly even if it was a straight
guy closer to her age he'd probably be
like no thanks yeah
just add another layer right a delusion
on her he's gay she's she and he's
obviously gay yeah and she's she still
thinks he's into her yeah
i mean yeah that's just like wants to go
out on dates and stuff and he's just
like yeah okay because he's just like i
said
they live in this big mansion so it's
like he figures they got money and i'm
gonna get my hands on it yeah and if
she's stupid enough to like think that
she's actually gonna go
on the road with this
idea that she has then it's like okay
i'm just gonna take all her money and
yeah he wanted what 200 a week
it was 100 a week 100 a week which back
in 1962 probably wasn't like a thousand
a week probably and she said that she
would pay him like a month in advance so
that was like four hundred dollars in
1962 which was probably nothing to
sneeze at yeah like four grand three
four grand probably yeah so so there was
that but like i said i mean his
character was great because
especially like when he first meets her
and she's like telling him like about
all these big plans that she has and she
ordered all these costumes just like her
old ones and all this other stuff and
just like the looks on it like his
expressions are just so good
[ __ ] funny i was just like the whole
time i'm just like i'm like look at his
face look at this yeah and she doesn't
see it no but he's just like turned on
he's like he's like oh yeah that's a
great idea we're totally going to do
that but he's just like
okay
it's so [ __ ] great babysitting it's
so [ __ ] great but yes she definitely
does think that he's like interested in
her because he she accuses blanche one
time because blanche tried to come down
and see like what the [ __ ] who is that
like she can't come downstairs because
she's paraplegic but um
but she tries to come down and see it's
like who the hell are you talking to
down there and she's like you can't calm
down you'll take him away from me and
all this other kind of [ __ ] she's trying
to steal him yeah she's trying to like
steal her man which like i said this
happened in real life like they had a
whole feud about like uh about in real
life like having a man steals i don't
know who stole who but that that was
kind of one of the source of their uh
acrimony like over the years but should
we spoil like the ending
like the the twist because this does
have a twist at the end
yeah well look you guys don't want to
don't know the end now it's time to
[ __ ] check off and i liked that the
twist the twist at the end really it
kind of like recontextualizes a lot of
what you saw like a lot of how you felt
about these characters you know what i
mean which i thought was like really
good i thought it was like a really good
twist and they didn't it didn't just
like you know come out of left field
they did kind of set it up a little bit
she tried to spill the beans earlier
yeah
yeah
but the thing about it is that yeah so
after she goes completely after jane
goes completely bug [ __ ] and kills um
elvira and then she like goes and dumps
her body someplace and the cops find the
body but they don't know she did it but
then basically she's like well i i have
to get out of here everyone's gonna when
they find out what i did they're gonna
be mean to me she says she's talking
like a kid like more and more
so she drags her sister out of the house
and puts her in the car and takes her to
the beach
and
she's just sitting out there on the
beach like in [ __ ]
plain as day it's daytime and there's
like people running blanche has been fed
in a long time that's what i mean i
think that see i think that she was
supposed to have been
like starving yeah um because there's
one point like i said she won't eat now
because she's afraid that you know she's
gonna feed her some [ __ ] um you know
justifiably so there's one scene where
she actually like sneaks into
jane's room like when she's gone and
goes and finds a big stash of like
chocolate and so she's like eating that
like stuff in her face like she's really
hungry but i guess she's supposed to be
starving because at this point like when
when jane takes her out of the house
she's dying because she's when um
because remember like uh what is victor
borno's character's name i don't know
uh flag edwin flag flag yeah so when he
comes to the house and sees her he's
like oh my god she's dying i have to get
the [ __ ] out of it i don't know if he
just like ran away or if he went to get
help
i thought he went to get help because
how would the cops have known that she
kidnapped her otherwise i think he went
to the cops he he went to the cops yeah
uh but in the context of the 60s that
was kind of a cowardly thing to do
yes because
he couldn't overcome overpower an old
lady and save another old city
yeah so
he had to go run to the cops to go get
help i mean in his defense he was super
drunk so he probably wasn't thinking
straight i think that he was really
really drunk yeah i think i think that's
that was the mitigating circumstance
yeah he was that's i think that's why
they made him like super drunk so but i
can be super drunk and do a lot of
damage i could do more damage drunk
well yeah sometimes i mean i guess it
would depend on the situation but yeah a
lot of times you can right so but i
think he was just so weirded out by the
whole thing that he was just like oh
[ __ ]
yeah and well and the cops had just been
there because he had been so he's like
oh that was probably just the first
thing he thought of like in his adult
brain oh i'll just go get the cops back
and see because like i said how would
they have known that right jane was
kidnapped
was to put her in danger because
i thought that [ __ ] jane was gonna
[ __ ] immediately pick up a knife and
kill her
yeah i thought i thought edwin was gonna
get killed too that's what would
probably happen in real life you
couldn't you couldn't leave her there
yeah you'd have to take her with you
yeah but so she's dying we're presuming
from like starvation and also
prior like would she kick the [ __ ] out
of her too so i'm sure that didn't maybe
she had some internal injuries but so
she drags her to the beach and like lays
her down and wraps her up and then she's
like oh yeah we're on the beach and blah
blah blah she's like i said she's
completely like lost contact with
reality at this point i'm gonna go get
us some ice cream and like meanwhile the
cops are like looking for her and [ __ ]
like that
and then they have this moment
where blanche is like you know hey i'm
dying uh hey i'm gonna tell you this
little piece of information
piece of information being you know how
all the time
this is spoiler alert spoiler alert you
know how all the time um
jane
thought that she had
run over
or that she was so drunk and she got mad
and she ran over blanche and she was the
one that paralyzed her and she was so
drunk that she didn't really remember
and uh basically blanche says no i did
that um what happened i was driving you
were too drunk to drive and you got out
of the car to open the gate and i was
gonna run over your ass because i hate
you so much and you pissed me off so
much at that party
and so she did the car forward and hit
the gate but like um but what's her name
but jane had like run out of the way
so she broke her own back she basically
broke she didn't mean to do that i think
but she was so it was an accident yeah
but
so but she just let
jane think that she had crippled her
sister all that time
for like psychological torture all those
years to like make her guilty and like
make her take care of her and all this
other kind so
even though the whole time you've been
watching blanche and she's like the
victim and she still is because you know
she probably didn't deserve to get
treated like that but she wasn't as
innocent in the whole thing as
it might have appeared at first because
she totally let jane
think that she had run her over so she
would have like all that guilt all that
time and that she would feel obligated
because that was a twist to take care of
her and like
and like you know throw her own life
away essentially just like having to
look after her because i made you ugly
that's funny
i was like damn yeah
she's like hey what the [ __ ] but yeah so
but the thing about it is that at this
point jane is so far gone that like the
cops come
and all these people gather around
because they're like hey that's the
chick we've been looking for and she
just thinks oh they're all here to watch
me and she starts like dancing
so it's like but you know what they
never do tell you if blanche lived or
died though i think she died i think she
lived
the cops went over that you see the cops
going over there yeah because i think
the cops go over there and like they go
and find her and then like the credits
right yeah i think i think it was
supposed to be kind of like a happy
ending that she was saved yeah but then
you found out that [ __ ] like i said it
didn't really excuse like all the [ __ ]
that jane had done to her over the years
but it's still like put another with her
dancing on the crowd
jane dancing in front of the crowd
you're left with the impression that her
ass [ __ ] gets institutionalized you
would imagine yeah and i'm sure they
probably figured out too that eventually
they would figure out that she'd killed
elvira because the neighbor like saw
elvira going into the house like shortly
before she disappeared so there's that
but yeah i mean elvira man duh she
[ __ ] says oh no we're not having any
of this [ __ ] she confronted her
yeah i mean elvira was a hero she was
like the heroic character yeah i liked
that she was really the only one that
mostly saw the extent of what was going
on trying to stop it and tried to stop
it yeah i mean she comes in the house
and like she sees like blanche's door is
locked she couldn't get it open she's
like [ __ ] this and she went and got like
a screwdriver and it's like pulling the
hinges off and [ __ ] like yeah she gets a
screwdriver and a hammer and starts
knocking the door off the hinges and
blanche shows up she [ __ ] confronts
and says you can open that door you know
and uh
she got in there eventually didn't she
yeah and see it and say sorry because
she had her like tied up by her because
she has you know a paraplegic have that
thing where you can get out of bed and
she was like oh you're basically she
says you're [ __ ] crazy what are you
doing she tries to go [ __ ] help her
and [ __ ]
and
jane picked up the hammer that she sat
down i said say you should have set the
hammer down
bam [ __ ] got her in the back of the
head while she was unhooking her yeah
don't ever sit down a hammer around a
crazy person just
[Laughter]
but yeah she was uh but yeah she did she
did get killed yeah yeah but blanche had
been trying to call her but she took all
the phones away [ __ ] she couldn't get
downstairs to get where the phone was
yeah and she did at one point she kind
of threw herself down because barbara
figured out something was wrong she was
giving she she fires her and pays her in
in person basically we don't need you
we're moving we're selling the house
and she's like yeah she kind of knew
that that was coming but this the order
isn't right she goes i want to see i
want to see blanche because oh no no i
don't remember what excuse she gave her
she's asleep she goes well i'll wake her
up and she's give me the key dude i
don't have the key yeah she didn't have
the keys yeah she had the keys she went
down to go wait for the bus and when she
saw a [ __ ]
jane jane leaving her car she walked
back to the house
went back in there and the neighbor saw
it because that's a key thing later on
and she went in there and she's calling
she said that this [ __ ] ain't right and
then she [ __ ] couldn't get into the
door
and blanche wouldn't answer so she went
into [ __ ] battle mode tried to take
the jump
yeah and uh jane came back and never had
a [ __ ] confrontation there it was
good it was a good scene it was actually
yeah there's like a lot of suspense in
this because like i said
just like um i think you know and
stephen king used this in misery as well
where somebody's like they're they're
constantly trying to get help but it's
always you know jane always comes back
or she always sees her or she always you
know [ __ ] like that and there were a
couple scenes toward the end where you
know blanche is trying to get down the
stairs to use the only like the only
working phone that's down there because
you know jane has pulled out all the
other ones and there was a scene where
we were just kind of like well why don't
you just like slide down the stairs on
your butt instead of like trying to
creep down but i think like i said i
think that she was they were implying
that she was supposed to be like super
super weak because she hadn't eaten so
she couldn't really like move all that
well so it was like this really
harrowing journey like down the stairs
like to the phone
so there was that but you know it's just
i don't know i just i i had forgotten
like how good this movie was i was
really really into it like this the
cinematography is great the acting is
great um and if you read about all of
the back the stuff going on between like
betty davis and joan crawford and
actually the same director um robert
aldrich that directed this couple years
later he also did um hush hush sweet
charlotte which we should probably do
that one too because that's also really
good that was supposed to be the two of
them again
um because this had been so successful
and betty davis is in it but joan
crawford was like oh i'm uh sick i can't
be in it and they think that probably
that she wasn't sick they think that she
was just mad because betty davis got an
oscar nomination and she didn't for this
movie and she didn't get one
so she's like [ __ ] that i'm not gonna be
in it so actually hush-hush sweet
charlotte has betty davis but then they
got olivia de havilland instead um of
joe crawford because she wouldn't do it
because it's just great i put this one
uh right at the same level as psycho one
it's as good i think it's i like it a
little bit better but it's as good this
would be a good this would be a good
double feature with psycho and whatever
happened baby jane yeah because they're
very i mean they're not similar similar
but there was like psychological yeah
kind of horror
i would like to know who that was that
played elvira and did she get any other
roles because i thought she did a good
job she looked slightly familiar yeah i
might have seen her in something else
there was you know the subtext there the
social subtext was uh
was was pretty good because
dick she came on a bus
which lets you know that she was lower
income yeah all right
and she's has to deal with these two ex
faint ex celebrity white women one of
them's [ __ ] crazy
all right
and
uh by the normal
social order when
when you're in a situation like that
you're just working as a hired hand
around somebody's house a bunch of rich
people and they tell you to get the [ __ ]
out you just gotta get the [ __ ] out
you're fired
all right yeah but she knew
something wasn't right and she likes
blanche yeah she was friends with
blanche she knew something wasn't right
and that she's like nah
i'm breaking the social the normal
social compact here i'm gonna go [ __ ]
go in that house yeah
and uh you could have gotten into big
trouble oh yeah i'm doing that that's
basically
it's entering not breaking and entering
it's entering because she had the key
yeah
and uh you could do a little bit time
for that
but she did it anyway which i thought
that was just a great character
somebody was standing up for something
that was right it didn't matter if it
was legal or not just
yeah she was easily the most heroic yeah
yeah yeah i mean i don't know
it's like the best chance for black i
knew that something bad was gonna happen
because you knew there was more time in
the movie so you knew it wasn't gonna
happen i was like
that should work it didn't work no yeah
yeah well like i said she's still and
the neighbors sargon underestimated yeah
but in yeah in a way people never die
yeah well because in a way because the
neighbors saw her go in
that ended up like getting baby jane
caught like later on so even in death
she
about yeah blanche and we're assuming
blair survived a good person had to die
i know
i was really bummed out that's part of
horror yeah as well that's well yeah
that's why this is a horror movie yeah
so yeah i mean if you haven't seen this
definitely uh kind of like how hallerin
had to die and [ __ ] shiny even though
he doesn't die in the book he doesn't
die in the book but he died in the movie
yeah he had to die it was a horror movie
well the thing about it and the thing
about the shining and i think i've
talked about this before i was really
bummed out because you know scat man
crothers is a [ __ ] legend yeah but
i i get why kubrick did that like why he
killed him somebody had to die well and
it made it a lot scarier yeah because
look at all of the [ __ ] that he went
through to get there right and you're
like oh he's gonna get there he's gonna
save him and then bam and i was like oh
[ __ ] he didn't save men life only saved
him in death yeah because he left the
snow cat which is kind of like what this
is right you know elvira didn't save
blanche in life she got killed but yeah
she did because they found her body in
the the the investigation they started
looking for yeah started looking for
everybody yeah so there was that and
because like i said she'd been seen by
the neighbor going into the house so
everybody just presumed there was a
connection so that's how you know uh
baby jane gets in trouble and was it a
worthwhile sacrifice who knows because
[ __ ] blanche tried to kill [ __ ]
jane earlier anyway
so that's that's all the [ __ ] mind
[ __ ] that horror is
real well written horror
yeah supposed to be that i kind of want
to read this bunch of more
gray morality where you're not sure
i just liked that that's why i like that
final twist because the whole time
you're sympathizing with blanche because
she just seems like this completely
innocent woman and she can't move and
stuff like that but then at the end you
find out she tried to kill herself she
actually tried to kill her sister first
and that she you know the accident and
that she let her think that like all
like 30-something years you did this to
me and like try to make her feel bad
about it so it might so she might have
been responsible yeah for her sister
like going off the deep end like that so
you know
uh but yeah so there was a whole that
was that whole thing but yeah so if you
haven't seen whatever happened to baby
jean or you haven't seen it for a long
time because i hadn't seen it since i
was a teenager definitely check it out
again because it's like so so much
better than i remembered and i really
really got into it and i'm glad that tom
really liked it too because like i said
i hadn't seen it in a while so i was
like i hope this is as good as i
remember uh we should probably do
hush-hush sweet charlotte too because i
remember that being really good also but
yeah it's on we watched it on hbo max
i'm sure it's probably some other places
as well but yeah check it out or if it's
one of your favorite movies uh from the
60s which is you know now one of mine uh
then let us know in the comments and
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys on
the next one bye